This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. At some point in your life, you probably encountered a problem in the built world, something that was poorly designed and the fix was obvious to you. Maybe a door that opened the wrong way, were a poorly painted marker on the road. I noticed this kind of stuff all the time, even more so now after creating the show. I'm sorry if you do too, because you listen to the show. And mostly when we see these things, we grumble on the inside, and then do nothing. There are all sorts of reasons for our inertia.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在你生命中的某个时刻，你可能在现实世界中遇到过一个问题，某样东西设计得很糟糕，而解决办法对你来说显而易见。也许是一扇开错方向的门，或者是路上一个涂画得很差的标志。我一直都能注意到这类事情，在制作这个节目后更是如此。如果你也这样，我很抱歉，因为你听了这个节目。通常当我们看到这些东西时，我们会在心里抱怨，然后什么也不做。我们产生这种惰性是有各种原因的。
We don't know how to fix it. It's not ours to fix. We could get in trouble. That's producer David Weinberg. You might notice these little design flaws for years silently fuming, until one day. He called me and said,
我们不知道怎么修。这不是我们该修的。我们可能会惹上麻烦。那是制片人大卫·温伯格。你可能会注意到这些小小的设计缺陷，默默地生气多年，直到有一天。他打电话给我说，
you know, okay, we're doing it. It was early Sunday morning, August 5th, 2001 in Los Angeles, California. Richard Encrum and a group of friends were on the fourth street bridge over the 110 Freeway. They were about to commit a crime. It's going to be a high profile of dangerous situation. Not only could I get arrested, I could kill somebody.
你知道，好吧，我们要做了。那是2001年8月5日，星期日清晨，加利福尼亚州洛杉矶。理查德·恩克拉姆和一群朋友在110号高速公路上的第四街大桥上。他们正准备犯罪。这将是一个备受瞩目且危险的情况。我不仅可能被捕，还可能害死某人。
Really, I was terrified of that. But let's back up. About 20 years prior, Richard Ancrum, an artist living in Orange County, was driving north on the 110 Freeway. As he passed through downtown Los Angeles, he was going to merge onto another freeway, the I-5 North. But he missed the exit and got lost. And for some reason, it just stuck with him. Years later, when Richard moved to downtown Los Angeles, he was driving on the same stretch of freeway where he'd gotten lost a decade before.
说真的，我对此感到恐惧。但让我们回顾一下。大约20年前，住在奥兰治县的艺术家理查德·恩克拉姆正开车在110号高速公路上向北行驶。当他经过洛杉矶市中心时，他打算并入另一条高速公路，即5号州际公路北向。但他错过了出口，迷路了。不知何故，这件事一直萦绕在他心头。多年后，当理查德搬到洛杉矶市中心时，他正开在那段他十年前迷路过的高速公路上。
When he looked up at the big green rectangular sign suspended above. I realize why I missed the exit is because it wasn't adequately signed. Bad way finding. The exit for the I-5 wasn't indicated on the green overhead sign. There was even a big open space where there should have been a blue and red interstate shield, and above that, it should have said North. It was clear to Richard that Cal Trans,
当他抬头看向悬挂在上方的大型绿色长方形标志时。我意识到我错过出口的原因是它没有足够的标志。糟糕的寻路系统。5号州际公路的出口没有在头顶的绿色标志上标出。甚至有一个很大的空白区域，本应有一个蓝色和红色的州际公路盾牌，在那上面，应该写着“北”。理查德很清楚，加州交通局，
the California Department of Transportation, had made a mistake. So Richard and artist and sign painter decided to make the interstate five North shield himself and install it in the place he thought it should have been all along, high above the 110 freeway. He would call it an act of guerrilla public service. All ideal is to be sort of a public servant
即加州交通运输部，犯了一个错误。于是，身为艺术家和标志画家的理查德决定自己制作那个“5号州际公路北向”的盾牌，并把它安装在他认为一直都应该在的地方，即110号高速公路的高处。他称之为一种“游击式公共服务”行为。所有的理想都是成为某种公务员，
or actually to show what you can do with artwork. You can put in plain sight and have it functioning, working thing for everyone to use. Richard started by studying LA freeway science, holding up pantone swatches to perfectly match the paint color. He dangled over bridges to measure the exact dimensions of other signs. And most importantly, he downloaded
或者实际上是展示你能用艺术品做什么。你可以把它放在显眼的地方，让它成为每个人都能使用的功能性东西。理查德首先研究了洛杉矶的高速公路标志，拿着潘通色卡来完美匹配油漆颜色。他悬挂在桥上测量其他标志的确切尺寸。最重要的是，他下载了
the Necronomicon of California Road signage, the Mutt Kid. The MUTCD, the manual on uniform traffic control devices, quote, to provide for uniform standards and specifications for all official traffic control devices in California. It's not a beach read. I have it as more of a lazy Sunday afternoon read. All the specs are online, so people can bid on projects. Richard wanted his sign to be built
加州道路标志的“死灵之书”，即《统一交通控制设备手册》（MUTCD），引用：“为加州所有官方交通控制设备提供统一的标准和规范。”这不是一本海滩读物。我把它当作一个慵懒的周日下午读物。所有的规格都在网上，这样人们就可以对项目进行投标。理查德希望他的标志能按照
to the exact specifications of cow trans, which were designed to be read by motorists traveling at high speeds. The shield with a five on it is three feet roughly high and wide. It's less than eight of an inch, barely an eighth of an inch thick aluminum. It's still pretty strong. And above that, I put the word north, and that was about 14 inches by five feet. And again, I used the same tight face that was there and the same signs.
加州交通局的确切规格建造，这些规格旨在供高速行驶的驾驶员阅读。上面带有数字5的盾牌大约有三英尺高和宽。它不到八分之一英寸厚，几乎只有八分之一英寸厚的铝板。它仍然相当坚固。在它上面，我放了“北”这个词，大约是14英寸乘5英尺。同样，我使用了那里现有的相同字体和相同的标志。
I tried to match everything as close as I could, so it wouldn't be obvious. CalTrans didn't do it. Richard's brand new additions had to blend in perfectly with the existing signage, which had been collecting dirt and smog for decades. I sprayed the whole thing with a really thin glaze of gray and knocked down the shine. After he finished it, Richard signed his name on the back of it with a black marker,
我尽量匹配所有东西，这样就不会显得很明显。加州交通局没有做这个。理查德全新的添加物必须与现有的标志完美融合，而现有的标志已经积攒了数十年的灰尘和烟雾。我用一层非常薄的灰色釉料喷涂了整个东西，并降低了光泽。完成后，理查德用黑色记号笔在背面签上了他的名字，
like a painter signing a canvas, then came the next phase of the project, the installation, which he planned with the precision of a bank heist. He bought a disguise, a white hard hat and an orange vest, so he'd look like a cow trans worker. Basically looked as best I could. And he made a decal for his pickup truck, meant to look vaguely official, that said, aesthetic deconstruction. The night before the installation, Richard drove out to the site and hid some of his supplies
就像画家在画布上签名一样，接下来是项目的下一阶段，安装，他像策划银行抢劫一样精确地计划了这次安装。他买了一套伪装，一顶白色安全帽和一件橙色背心，这样他看起来就像加州交通局的工人。基本上看起来尽我所能。他还为他的皮卡车制作了一个贴纸，看起来模棱两可地官方，上面写着“美学解构”。安装的前一天晚上，理查德开车到现场并藏好了一些他的用品，
so they'd be easy to get to the next morning. When I interviewed him he took me to the spot and showed me where he'd stashed his stuff. Okay we're basically here. Right now the ivy isn't that thick but it was a lot thicker and I had basically behind that tree it stashed the ladder and the signs and stuff. After he hid his things he climbed a tree and just sat there, going through everything in his head.
这样第二天早上就很容易拿到。当我采访他时，他带我去了那个地方，并向我展示了他藏东西的地方。好吧，我们基本上到了。现在常春藤没那么厚，但当时厚得多，我基本上在那棵树后面藏了梯子和标志之类的东西。藏好东西后，他爬上一棵树，坐在那里，在脑海中梳理了一遍所有事情。
I just sort of called myself down by being there and hanging around with it the night before. Richard was worried that he might drop the sign or one of his tools onto the road below. Drivers going 60 plus miles an hour would have no time to react if something landed on the road in front of them or worse onto their car. That was a scariest thing of the whole project. Is if somebody got hurt, you know, I'd have to live with that.
我只是通过前一天晚上在那里待着并和它待在一起，让自己冷静下来。理查德担心他可能会把标志或工具掉到下面的路上。如果有什么东西掉在他们面前的路上，或者更糟的是掉在他们的车上，时速60英里以上的驾驶员将没有时间反应。那是整个项目中最可怕的事情。如果有人受伤，你知道，我必须带着这种愧疚生活。
And then the project, I'd have to sh** can it, because it would have defeated the whole idea of it. But despite some reservations, Richard was pretty confident he could pull the whole thing off, and he'd gone too far to turn back. And that brings us back to the morning of August 5th, 2001. Richard did not act alone. He asked several friends to film the installation from different vantage points. Amy Inoa was one of the
然后这个项目，我就得把它毁掉，因为它违背了整个初衷。但尽管有一些顾虑，理查德还是相当自信他能完成这一切，而且他已经走得太远，无法回头了。这把我们带回了2001年8月5日的早晨。理查德并不是一个人行动。他请了几位朋友从不同的角度拍摄安装过程。艾米·伊诺亚是其中一位
friends he enlisted the film. We did it at 6am or 7am on a Sunday morning. It was tense because we all thought we were going to get into trouble. Richard had chosen a Sunday morning to put up the sign, knowing that there would be little traffic and the morning light rising above the skyscrapers would be just right for filming. What he hadn't anticipated was that cow trans had also picked that morning to do work on the same stretch of highway. Yes, they happened to be doing some other work on the freeway just south of that sign. When they saw the cow trans workers, they thought about turning back.
他招募来拍摄的朋友。我们在周日早上6点或7点做的。当时很紧张，因为我们都以为会惹上麻烦。理查德选择在周日早上安装标志，因为他知道那时交通很少，而且摩天大楼上升起的晨光非常适合拍摄。他没预料到的是，加州交通局也选了那个早晨在同一段高速公路上施工。是的，他们碰巧在那个标志南边的高速公路上做其他工作。当他们看到加州交通局的工人时，他们想过要回头。
But I had surmised after all this is a pretty large city that would be more than one sign crew. My assumption was they'd think the other guy was doing it. Richard parked his truck and when everyone was in position with their cameras He went to work. The hardest part really was getting over the razor wire with the ladder. Once he was up on the catwalk nearly 30 feet above the highway He started screwing in the new sign. Careful not to drop any screws on the cars below. Half way into it, we just felt like okay, he's gonna get away with it. The whole thing took less than 30 minutes. As soon as it was up Richard packed up his ladder rushed back to his truck and blended back into the city.
但我推测，毕竟这是一个相当大的城市，应该不止一个标志施工队。我的假设是他们会以为是另一队人在做。理查德停好车，当每个人都带着摄像机就位后，他开始工作。最难的部分其实是带着梯子翻过铁丝网。一旦他爬上高速公路上方近30英尺高的猫道，他就开始拧上新标志。小心不要把任何螺丝掉在下面的车上。进行到一半时，我们觉得好吧，他会成功的。整个过程不到30分钟。标志一装好，理查德就收拾好梯子，冲回他的卡车，融入了城市之中。
I think we all went out to breakfast together after words and we were super relieved and really happy. Only a small group of people knew that the interstate five shield with the word north hanging above the 110 freeway was a forgery. He didn't say to us don't tell anyone, so our friends all knew about it and we would drive by it and we would just all feel really happy about it. But it never sort of managed to leak out past that small group. For a while. For a while. For nine months, the secret stayed within a small group. For a while. For a while. For nine months, the secret stayed within a small community.
我想我们事后一起去吃了早餐，我们感到超级如释重负，非常开心。只有一小群人知道悬挂在110号高速公路上方带有“北”字的5号州际公路盾牌是伪造的。他没有对我们说“别告诉任何人”，所以我们的朋友都知道这件事，我们会开车经过它，我们都会为此感到非常高兴。但它从未泄露给那个小圈子之外的人。有一段时间。有一段时间。九个月来，这个秘密一直保存在一个小群体内。有一段时间。有一段时间。九个月来，这个秘密一直保存在一个小社区内。
And then Richard's friend Gary leaked the story. Oh, what the hell, Gary? Why can't you be cool? Just be cool, Gary! Richard's secret was out to CalTrans and to the press. From the fake magnetic sign on his beat up blue truck to a work order proclaiming rush. But he did is against the law, but CalTrans says it has no plans at all to foul charges against him. After they found out what had happened, apparently they sent a grout there he was inspected.
然后理查德的朋友加里泄露了这个故事。哦，搞什么鬼，加里？你为什么不能冷静点？冷静点，加里！理查德的秘密被加州交通局和媒体知道了。从他那辆破旧蓝色卡车上的假磁性标志，到一份宣称“紧急”的工作单。但他所做的是违法的，但加州交通局表示根本没有计划对他提出指控。在他们发现发生了什么事后，显然他们派了一个小组去检查。
Richard was hoping to get his sign back from CalTrans after they took it down. He was thinking he would hang it in an art gallery. But CalTrans didn't take the sign down. It passed the CalTrans inspection because that's really the final test of how good the artwork is. It stayed up for eight years, nine months, and 14 days, I believe it's not exactly accurate, but it's pretty close to that. In interviews about the incident with other news organizations, CalTrans didn't exactly condone Richard's handiwork, but they were pretty kind about it. Here's the CalTrans spokesperson at the time.
理查德希望在加州交通局拆除标志后能拿回它。他想把它挂在艺术画廊里。但加州交通局并没有拆除那个标志。它通过了加州交通局的检查，因为那确实是艺术品质量的最终考验。它在那里挂了八年、九个月零14天，我相信这不是完全准确，但非常接近。在接受其他新闻机构关于此事的采访时，加州交通局并没有完全宽恕理查德的手艺，但他们对此相当友善。这是当时加州交通局的发言人。
He did a good job, but we don't want him to do it again. And in fact, he did such a good job that I'd like to offer him a job application. More than eight years after Richard's sign went up, he got a call from a friend who noticed some workers taking it down. Richard contacted CalTrans to ask if he could have his sign back. By the time I tracked him down, it had already been crushed into a bale going for China. And who knows what it turned into could be a waffle iron by now. After Kaltrans took down Richard's sign, they replaced it with a brand new one. But this
他做得很好，但我们不希望他再做一次。事实上，他做得太好了，我想给他提供一份工作申请。在理查德的标志挂出八年多后，他接到一个朋友的电话，说看到一些工人在拆除它。理查德联系了加州交通局，询问是否能拿回他的标志。当我找到他时，它已经被压成一捆运往中国了。谁知道它变成了什么，现在可能是一个华夫饼机。加州交通局拆除理查德的标志后，换上了一个全新的。但这次，
time, they incorporated his ideas into the new design. They added the five north and the shield not only to that sign, but to additional ones up the road. A little epilogue. Richard's highway sign is a happily ever after story. The sign worked. People appreciated it. No one got hurt, thankfully. Even Count Trans was really pretty nice about the whole thing. There's another gorilla sign story out of New York City, a group that calls itself the Efficient Passengers Project, has been hanging signs in New York subway stations to tell
他们把他的想法融入了新设计中。他们不仅在那个标志上，还在路上的其他标志上添加了“5号北向”和盾牌。一个小尾声。理查德的高速公路标志是一个皆大欢喜的故事。标志起作用了。人们很欣赏它。谢天谢地，没有人受伤。甚至加州交通局对整件事也相当不错。纽约市还有另一个游击标志故事，一个自称为“高效乘客项目”的组织，一直在纽约地铁站悬挂标志，告诉
people where they can board the train to make the most efficient transfers. The project is not at all affiliated with the Metropolitan Transit Authority, but the signs look just like MTA signs, black with white helvetical lettering. They say things like, board here for best transfer to the four, five, and six trains, or board here for best transfer to F and M trains. It's the kind of knowledge that you build up over time as a regular subway rider, and this guerrilla signmaker is offering it to everyone. And though some have applauded the signs, not all New Yorkers are pleased.
人们在哪里可以上车以实现最高效的换乘。该项目与大都会运输署（MTA）完全没有关联，但这些标志看起来就像MTA的标志，黑色背景，白色Helvetica字体。它们写着诸如“在此上车以获得前往4、5、6号线的最佳换乘”或“在此上车以获得前往F和M线的最佳换乘”。这是你作为一名常规地铁乘客随着时间推移而积累的知识，而这位游击标志制作者正把它提供给每个人。虽然有些人称赞这些标志，但并非所有纽约人都感到高兴。
These are secrets, some say, that people should have to earn. They will unbalance the cars, they say, leave signage to the experts. The MTA, for their part, is taking down the signs as fast as they go up. MTA spokesman Kevin Ortiz told us in an email that, quote, posting of the signs is considered an act of vandalism. Point me if you decide to undertake an act of Gorilla Public Service, just know it may not be received as such. 99% Invisible was produced this week by David Weinberg with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Avery, Trouffleman, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW, San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of Arxan.
有些人说，这些是秘密，人们应该自己去争取。他们说，这会使车厢失去平衡，把标志留给专家吧。MTA方面则在以标志出现的速度拆除它们。MTA发言人凯文·奥尔蒂斯在电子邮件中告诉我们，引用：“张贴这些标志被视为一种破坏行为。”如果你决定进行“游击式公共服务”行为，请注意它可能不会被那样看待。《99%隐形》本周由大卫·温伯格制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我，罗曼·马斯共同参与。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Arxan的办公室制作。
In architecture and interior sperm, damn good one, if you ask me, if you ask anyone really. In beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, we're all on Twitter and Instagram. Every runs the Tumblr, I make the Spotify playlist of 99 PI songs, but I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% Invisible at 99pion.org. Radio tilpion from PRX.
一家建筑和室内设计公司，如果你问我，这是一家非常棒的公司，如果问任何人真的。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们都在Twitter和Instagram上。Every负责Tumblr，我制作了99 PI歌曲的Spotify播放列表，但我鼓励你在99pion.org探索99%隐形的整个世界。来自PRX的Radio Topion。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。